So now, we have seen that in MSI
even when we have an intervention,
we need to write to memory every time
we have a cache to cache transfer.
So, for example, C1 has the block in
the M state because it just wrote it.
C2 wants to read the data, so
it puts a read request on the bus.
C1 responds with the data.
So now C2 has the date, but C1 can
no longer just write to this block.
So C1 gets the block in the shared
state, C2 gets the block in the shared
state, and that's why the memory had to
grab the data when C1 was responding.
Now what can happen is C2 writes so
it sends an invalidation because
it already has the data.
Now C1 gets invalid state,
C2 gets the modified state,
and and then let's say this read write
behavior moves to another core, like C1.
So pretty much, if one core reads and
writes, then another one reads and
writes and so on,
we can have a repetition of this.
So pretty much the data is kind
of moving around the caches, but
the problem is,
every time it moves between caches,
the memory also gets written.
And the memory doesn't have as
much bandwidth as the caches do.
So the problem really is that here
we needed to do a memory write.
Another problem occurs because,
when C2 has written, for example,
and has the data in the modified state,
and then C2 responds with data and
that causes a memory write, we again
get C1 has the block in shared state.
C2 has the block in shared state.
Now if C3 reads, because both of these
have the block in the shared state,
the memory provides the data.
So we have memory reads here even though
one of these could have responded with
the data, if we only knew which
of the two should respond.
Definitely both of them
should not respond.
So if we had a way to tell which
one of them should respond
we could avoid this memory read,
by the one that is responsible for
responding providing the data as
long as there are new requestors.
This can happen a lot of times.
So if another core reads,
same thing, we get the memory read,
although now there are three cores with
the data in the shared state, and so on.
We want to avoid the update to memory
as long as there is a cache that still
holds the most recent
value of the block.
And we want to avoid memory
reads if there is a cache that
can provide this block.
Because again, memory bandwidth is
a lot lower than cache bandwidth.
And also memory writes are a lot
more expensive in terms of power and
latency then cache reads and writes.
But to do this, we need to make
a non-modified version of the block in
one of the caches responsible for
giving data to other
caches when they want it so that
the memory doesn't need to respond and
eventually writing the block to
memory so that the memory doesn't
need to be updated every time
we do something like this.
So what we really need to
know is which of the shared
copies is the one responsible.
And we will know this by
introducing another state called O,
which stands for owned.
So there will be one owner of
the blog if others are sharing it.
The O state will behave
just like the shared state,
except that whenever
there is a request for
the data in the block, the owner is one
of the sharers that gets to respond.
And also if the owner replaces
the block from the cache,
it gets right back to memory so
that we ensure that memory gets updated.